"Scotty" on Star Trek Was Shot Six Times on
D-Day
Famed Star Trek actor, James Doohan a.k.a.
“Scotty”, was shot six times during WWII.
How did this happen?
After leading his men through a mine field
on Juno beach and personally taking out two
German snipers in the process, Doohan took
four rounds in one of his legs; one in his
hand, which ultimately resulted in him losing
his middle finger; and one in his chest.
The shot to the chest likely would have been
fatal except that he had a silver cigarette
case there that deflected the bullet.
He would later give up smoking, but at least
he could say that being a smoker actually
saved his life.
Funny enough, the shots he took were not fired
by the enemy, but rather by an overzealous
Canadian gunman.
After Doohan’s unit was secured in their
position for the night, he was crossing between
command posts when a Canadian gunman spotted
him and opened fire.
Doohan originally joined the Canadian Forces
at the age of 19, eventually being commissioned
a Lieutenant in the Royal Canadian Artillery.
D-Day was the first and last action he saw
in the war.
After recovering from his injuries, he became
a pilot in the Canadian Air Force, but never
flew in combat.
Despite this, he was once called “the craziest
pilot in the Canadian Air Force” when he
flew a plane through two telegraph poles after
“slaloming” down a mountainside, just
to prove it could be done.
This act was not looked upon highly by his
superiors, but earned him a reputation among
the pilots of the Canadian Air Force.
Bonus Facts:
• As mentioned, contrary to what many people
think, Doohan was not Scottish.
He was Canadian.
When he was auditioning for the role of the
ship’s engineer, he went over various accents
for Gene Roddenberry for the character.
After he finished, Roddenberry asked him which
he liked best and he responded: “Well, if
you want an engineer, he better be a Scotsman
because, in my experience, all the world’s
best engineers have been Scottish.”
• While great pains were taken in Star Trek
to conceal the fact the Doohan was missing
a middle finger, there are several episodes
where this can be observed, such as Cat’s
Paw; Day of the Dove and The Lights of Zetar.
This can also be observed in a scene in Star
Trek III: The Search for Spock and In Star
Trek V: The Final Frontier.
In the former, it can be observed when he
hands McCoy parts for the Transwarp Drive
and in the latter when he’s holding bagged
dinner which was given to him by Lt. Uhura.
• Doohan was married three times in his
life and fathered four children.
He met his final wife, Wende Braunberger,
when she was just 17 and he was 54, marrying
her very shortly after their first meeting.
The two had three children, the last in 2000,
and remained married for 31 years until Doohan’s
death in 2005 at the age of 85.